S
THAT HAVE BEEN OFFICIALLY
APPROVED BY LOUDOUN COUNTY
TEACHERS.
HERE IS A MAN CALLED BRANDON ME
SEAN, TRYING TO READ MORE FROM
THOSE BOOKS.
DARING TO READ ALOUD FROM THE
BOOKS THAT LOUDOUN COUNTY
CHILDREN ARE TOLD TO READ.
WATCH HOW THEY TRY AND SHUT HIM
UP AS HE DOES.
>> I'M GOING TO READ AN EXPERT
FROM A FRESHMAN HONORS ENGLISH
CLASS IN STONEBRIDGE.
"SHE IS A -- [BLEEP] EVERY DUDE
ON THE COURT."
IT IS TIME FOR LC PS TO GET
THEIR ACT IN ORDER.
THE CURTAIN HAS BEEN PULLED BACK
AND PEOPLE CAN NOW SEE THE
DEFICIENT LEADERSHIP.
MY FIVE EUROS BEING PEDDLED
TRANSGENDER BOOKS IN HER
LIBRARY, TEENAGERS ARE BEING
SERVED PORNOGRAPHY UNDER THE
GUISE OF YOUNG ADULT LITERATURE.
DO SOMETHING!
BE A LEADER!
THE CITIZENS OF THIS COUNTY
DESERVE BETTER AND IF YOU ARE
NOT WILLING TO DO IT --
>> PLEASE COVER YOUR NOSE WITH
YOUR MASK?
>> WHAT THE FREAK?
GIVE ME TEN SECONDS BACK.
>> SARAH, YOU KNOW THE RULES.
THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: WHERE YOUR MASK
WHEN YOU CRITICIZE US!
IT'S A PANDEMIC!
IN THE END, THEY JUST CUT OFF
HIS MIC.
ON THIS SHOW, WE ARE HAPPY TO
HEAR WHAT HE HAS TO SAY, SO THAT
MAN, BRANDON MICHON, JOINS US
RIGHT NOW.
BRANDON, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
YOU WERE TOLD TO WEAR YOUR
OBEDIENCE MASK WHEN YOU SPEAK TO
YOUR ELDERS, AND THEN IN THE
END, THEY JUST SHUT OFF THE P.A.
SYSTEM AND WOULD NOT LET YOU
TALK AT ALL.
SO FINISH HER SENTENCE, IF YOU
WOULD COME ON THE SHOW.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO CUT YOUR
MIKE.
WHAT WERE YOU TRYING TO TELL THE
SCHOOL BOARD OF SPEED 21?
>> THE MESSAGE TO THE SCHOOL
BOARD'S PARENTS ARE FED UP AND
THE CURTAIN HAS BEEN PULLED
BACK, ACROSS THE U.S., IN THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM, AND WHAT WE
ARE SEEING AND WHAT YOU SAW IN
THE VIDEOS YOU POSTED BEFORE,
THE CHILDREN ARE BEING SHOWN
MATERIAL THAT HOLLYWOOD CAN'T
EVEN MAKE INTO A MOVIE THAT THEY
CAN WATCH, SO I'M JUST ASKING
FOR THEM TO STEP UP AND BE
LEADERS, AND IF YOU'RE NOT
WILLING TO DO IT, STEP ASIDE, OR
IF YOU'RE NOT WILLING TO DO IT,
FIND A WAY FOR OTHERS TO YOU
KNOW FIND A SOLUTION FOR YOU.
>> Tucker: ONE THING I NOTICED
ABOUT ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
REVOLUTIONARY CHANGES THEY ARE
INFLICTING ON OUR KIDS AS THEY
ARE ALL DUMB.
AND THE STANDARDS HAVE BEEN
COMPLETELY DEBASED SO WE CAN'T
TEACH MATH BECAUSE IT IS RACIST,
CAN'T TEACH REAL BOOKS BECAUSE
THEY ARE RACIST, BUT THE THINGS
THAT REPLACE MATH IN THE
LITERATURE ARE DUMB.
THEY ARE NOT WELL WRITTEN.
THEY ARE NOT SMART.
WE ARE MAKING THE KIDS DUMB.
ARE THEY AWARE OF THIS?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK EVERY TIME WE ASK FOR
ANSWERS, THERE IS NO RESPONSE.
YOU ARE SEEING LOCAL OFFICIALS
LOOKING TO STATE OFFICIALS WHO
ARE LOOKING TO THE NATIONAL
GOVERNMENT WHO IS LOOKING
BACKWARDS TO STATE AND LOCAL.
WHAT WE NEED IS OUR SCHOOL
BOARDS TO BRING BACK TO
EDUCATION.
WE NEED OUR SCHOOL BOARDS TO PUT
EACH OTHER ACCOUNTABLE.
WE NEED THEM TO SAY ENOUGH'S
ENOUGH.
IF YOU HAVE AN ADMINISTRATION
WHO HAS PUT IN MATERIAL THAT
ISN'T APPROPRIATE, MAKE A
CHANGE, BUT IF YOU ARE NOT
WILLING TO DO THAT, THEN LISTEN
TO THE PARENTS BECAUSE THEY ARE
THE ONES WHO ARE HAVING TO DEAL
WITH US ON A DAILY BASIS.
>> Tucker: THIS IS AT LEAST
THE SECOND TIME THAT YOU HAVE
TOLD THE SCHOOL BOARD WHAT YOU
THINK.
HOW HAVE PEOPLE IN YOUR
COMMUNITY REACTED TO THOSE
WIDELY SHARED VIDEOS OF YOU
TELLING THE TRUTH IN THE SCHOOL
BOARD MEETING?
>> IT'S BEEN OVERALL POSITIVE.
I HAVE HEARD FROM PEOPLE ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY SAY THANKS
FOR SPEAKING UP, THANKS FOR
BEING AN ADVOCATE FOR THE
STUDENTS, BUT WHAT WE ARE TRYING
TO DO AT LEAST LOCALLY IS TRYING
TO GET THE SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS
OUT OF THERE.
THIS LAST WEEKEND, WE GOT 1500
SIGNATURES TO TRY TO REMOVE SIX
OF THE BOARD MEMBERS WHO ARE
ACTIVELY NOT TRYING TO
PARTICIPATE AND PUT THE
EDUCATION FIRST.
THEY CARE MORE ABOUT THEMSELVES
AND WHAT THEY POST ON FACEBOOK
THAN THEY DO ABOUT THE BETTER
EDUCATION OF YOUNG STUDENTS.
>> Tucker: I CAN'T SAY THIS
STRONGLY ENOUGH.
BLESS YOU FOR NOT BEING PASSIVE
AND FOR TRYING TO FIX IT.
REALLY QUICK, DO YOU THINK YOU
CAN GET SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS
BOUNCED?
SOON?
>> I WOULD HOPE SO.
WE BUILT A LOT OF MOMENTUM.
THE THING IS COME ALL ACROSS THE
U.S., PARENTS ARE BECOMING VOCAL
AND WHAT -- TEACHERS HAVE
UNIONS, BUT STUDENTS DON'T HAVE
A UNION.
WHAT THEY HAVE HIS PARENTS WHO
CARE FOR THEM AND PARENTS WHO
WANT TO SEE THEIR BEST
EDUCATION, AND WHAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO DO IS FIGHT FOR
THAT.
THE BEST EDUCATION FOR OUR
FAMILIES AND OUR CHILDREN.
>> Tucker: THAT'S RIGHT.
STAY AND FIGHT